We said already that is only one of
the two ways to do cohe snoopingrence.
The other way is
directory-based coherence.
So let's first see why do we even
want directory-based coherence?
What's wrong with snooping?
In snooping, we had to broadcast
all of the requests we make so
that others can see them.
And also to establish ordering, for
example, for writes, we need to
establish the ordering so that we can
obey the third coherence property.
But that means that there needs
to be a single bus on which
all of the requests from all of
the cores go, both cache misses and
also coherence requests that are just
sending out invalidations and so on.
So the bus that we were using for
broadcast becomes a bottleneck, and
as a result,
snooping does not really work well
if we have more than something
like eight to 16 cores.
Beyond that point, most of the time
the cores are just standing waiting for
the bus to put requests on it, so
really we get no further
benefit from additional course.
So what we need to solve this
bottleneck is a non-broadcast
network over which we're
going to send our requests.
So that many requests could be going
on at the same time, but then we have
the problems of how do we observe
those requests that we need to see.
So, for example, if we are in a shared
state, it had better be that when
there is a write by somebody else,
we observe that write so
that we can move to the invalid
state to avoid incoherence.
And also, how do we decide
what the ordering is for
requests that go to the same block?
So, for example, how do we decide what's
the ordering between writes done at
different cores, if this request can be
made on different parts of the network
and the structure that does
this is called a directory.